bei uns sitzt maria nori die gerade in
afghanistan war drei wochen dort
unterwegs war die eine sehr bewegende
dokumentation mitgebracht hat werden uns
an die ereignisse vor einem jahr
vielleicht kommen noch mal ein paar
bilder zeigen ist auch meine ernährung
zu rufen was dort unter anderem am
flughafen in kabul los war hilfskräfte
ortskräfte ist eines der stichworte dass
wir reden und ich würde gerne frau nuria
den punkt fragen sie als jemand der in
afghanistan geboren wurde im alter von
drei jahren dort weggegangen ist dann
ich glaube im wesentlichen hamburg
aufgewachsen ist aber nie den kontakt
zur heimat sozusagen wirklich verloren
hat jetzt zurückgekehrt ist für diese
reportage mit vielen menschen gesprochen
hat wie schauen sie auf alles was krieg
ist was waffen sind was militärisch
können waffen ernsthaft eine gute
antwort sein um irgendwo frieden im land
zu bringen
das ist eine sehr sehr große frage
und
bei mir ist das so ich bin in einer
ukrainischen afghanischen familie
aufgewachsen
das heißt ich war mein ganzes leben lang
zeugen davon wie
menschen aufgrund von krieg ihre heimat
verlassen müssen und hier von vorne
beginnen
und dabei macht es keinen unterschied ob
du aus afghanistan oder aus der ukraine
kommt ihre mutter ist ukrainerin ganna
und ihr vater ist das gar keiner und
mittlerweile sind fast alle meine
familienmitglieder kriegsflüchtlinge
und ich glaube das zu beobachten als
jemand der selbst kein krieg kennt und
so geht es sehr sehr viele nutzer jetzt
auch mit dem thema konfrontiert ist hier
genau und viele in unserer gesellschaft
wissen nicht wie krieg sich anfühlt
ricken krieg nur aus dem fernsehen und
solange ist es auch noch weit weg ich
glaube bei mir persönlich hat das zu
einer gewissen demut geführt was das
thema krieg angeht und
wenn wir afghanistan betrachten
und sehen was dort am ende
herausgekommen ist aufgrund von 40 jahre
krieg ein historisches szenario es ist
eine terrorgruppe an der macht
das sollte schon zum nachdenken
regen
wie weit wir gehen möchten was der plan
ist dabei und welche routen linien wie
überschneiden wollen und ich persönlich
habe eine große demut vor dem thema
krieg und kann mich nicht so stark damit
identifizieren mich dafür auszusprechen
zusagen mehr waffen mehr druck und
[Musik]
das heißt sie schon skeptisch auf diese
debatten die dann auch in der deutschen
öffentlichkeit geführt werden und sagen
ich hab das ich habe das elend gesehen
jetzt auch wieder vereinen oder mit
eigenen augen was hätte denn mit blick
auf afghanistan was hätte diesen an sich
ja so wunderschönen land was hätte den
geholfen in den letzten jahren was wäre
denn der bessere weg gewesen dass die
sogenannte westliche strategie für mich
gescheitert ist kann man glaube ich hier
einfach müssen festhalten
das ist
ich bin keine strategien der nato aber
sie sprechen mit den leuten nun genau
ich spreche mit den leuten und wenn wir
die geschichte afghanistans betrachten
und die uhren immer weiter und weiter
zurück drehen dann müssen wir erst mal
damit anfangen dass es ohne den
sowjetisch afghanischen krieg und der
unterstützung der usa damals gar keine
taliban gegeben hätte das ist das
allererste die taliban sind ein produkt
des krieges und und ein produkt
amerikanischer wasserlieferungen genau
und so sehr auch das bedürfnis
vielleicht da ist in momenten wenn
kriege sehr auf kochen oder diesen auf
trends zu helfen und zu sagen wir müssen
ein volk dabei unterstützen sich zu
verteidigen und so verständnisvoll das
auch ist wissen wie in diesem moment
nicht was am ende mit unseren waffen
passiert wie können wir garantieren dass
die waffen nicht am ende in den händen
des feindes landen dass die waffen nicht
am ende gegen uns selbst genutzt werden
und wie wollen wir das ganze auch in
zukunft abbauen und in der afghanischen
geschichte hat man ja sehr gut gesehen
wie die waffen die von amerika geliefert
worden später gegen die amerikaner
selbst benutzt wurden und das riesige
waffenarsenal das jetzt in afghanistan
heute noch da ist nicht abgebaut werden
konnte und das land extrem die
stabilisiert hat in all den jahren das
heißt du schaust du schaust irgendwann
in den lauf des gewehres dass du gestern
noch selber geliefert hast
möglicherweise und die frage ist welche
kontrollmechanismen gibt es ein chaos
des krieges bekam etwas überschaubarer
ist solche dinge zu verhindern in
afghanistan haben wir gesehen ist gab
sie nicht defacto
ein jahr nach dieser machtübernahme
durch die taliban wie ist die situation
in afghanistan sie berichten von
bitterer armut wegen des wassers
vorstellen
man muss in afghanistan wissen dass es
schon immer eines der ärmsten länder der
welt war und durch den regime wechsel
befindet sich afghanistan eigentlich
wirtschaftlich kurz vor dem kollaps und
das hat aber auch nur sage ich mal
bedingt es ist nur bedingt schuld der
taliban weil man muss über afghanistan
wissen dass afghanistan in eine
staatlichkeit gezüchtet wurde die
komplett in abhängigkeit von
ausländischen geldern stand das heißt 75
prozent der ausgaben afghanistans wurden
über ausländische gelder finanziert das
ist von heute auf morgen weg gebrochen
das bedeutet die wirtschaft steht
eigentlich kurz vor dem kollaps die
menschen 97 prozent der menschen in
afghanistan sind von der armut bedroht
die hälfte der bevölkerung
muss ernährt werden weil sie dem
hungertod bedroht sind und afghanistan
besteht befindet sich wirtschaftlich in
einer schlimmeren situation als vorher
das heißt menschen sind zu fast allem
bereit um ihre familie irgendwie
durchzubringen sie haben uns eine kurze
sequenz mitgebracht eine frau die sie
glaube ich zufällig auf der straße
treffen und die ihnen an den
unglaublichen handel vorschlägt eine
bettlerin auf der straße möchte mir baby
verkaufen sie kann es nicht mehr
ernähren ich gebe mich als journalistin
zu erkennen und sie liebt mich zu sich
nach hause ein
wir haben früher nicht gebettelt wir
hatten ein tolles leben als die taliban
an die macht gekommen sind sind wir so
abgestürzt ich bin gezwungen mich von
meinem geliebten kind zu treiben
wir haben heute morgen nichts gegessen
dann sehen sie selbst es ist nicht
mal was ist die geschichte dieser
familie
nur noch mal für den hintergrund ich
muss an ein gespräch jedes mal wenn ich
diese geschichte sehe muss ich an eines
der gespräche eines der ersten gespräche
denken die ich mit einem taliban
sprecher hatte das war als wir in
afghanistan angekommen sind und ich
hatte ihn direkt auf die wirtschaftslage
angesprochen und ihm auch gesagt wir in
deutschland haben hier viele geschichten
gehört von menschen die zum äußersten
getrieben wurden wie etwa als müssen
ihre organe verkaufen und ihre kinder
verkaufen daraufhin hat er gesagt das
ist alles propaganda das ist nicht wahr
und es gibt diese einzelfälle aber das
ist hier kein status quo und
hat das komplett geleugnet diese
realität und ich persönlich habe mich
nach dieser geschichte gesucht weil ich
auch dachte das sind eventuell
einzelfälle und tatsächlich die
allererste bettlerin mit der ich auf der
straße ins gespräch gekommen bin war sie
und sie wollte mir für 500 dollar ihr
kind verkaufen wie sie monate altes baby
und
somit ist diese geschichte dann am ende
doch zu uns gekommen und diese
geschichte hat am ende so viel erzählt
denn diese familie das waren wirklich
menschen die besonders stark an die
versprechen des westens geglaubt haben
ihr mann war soldat lebt heute in
verborgenen in angst entdeckt zu werden
sie haben von heute auf morgen alles
verloren es gibt keinen plan b es gibt
keine arbeit für diese menschen und die
hatten vorher ein leben ein gutes leben
und
heute stehen sie vor dem nichts und das
sind genau genau die menschen denen wir
eigentlich versprochen hatten sie nicht
im stich zu lassen
das heißt es stimmt auch was ich von
einem kollegen unlängst gehört habe da
sagt ja da gibt es ganze dörfer an den
menschen mit einer niere unterwegs sind
es stimmt er stimmt die situation ist
verheerend dort und weil die weil sie
das andere ghana verkaufen bitte weil
sie das andere organe verkaufen die zwei
teenager verkaufen sind diese breiten
genau diese also die menschen sind
gezwungen aktuell aufgrund der
wirtschaftlichen lage es gibt keine
arbeit die gelder sind eingefroren die
taliban sind sanktioniert es gibt auch
keinen plan wie wir mit den taliban
umgehen wollen so richtig und
letztendlich geht es darum die die
regierung zu die selbsternannte
regierung zu bestreiten aber wir
bestrafen gerade das volk kollektiv und
die menschen werden wirklich ins zum
äußersten gezwungen sein ihre organe zu
verkaufen oder sich von ihren kindern zu
trennen und wir haben ja jahrzehntelang
eigentlich auch diesen krieg damit
legitimiert dass wir den frauen helfen
möchten die frauenrechte vorantreiben
möchten und ich frage mich was hilft ist
dieser frau jetzt dass sie so weit
getrieben wird sich von ihrem kleinkind
einem mädchen eventuell trends müssen
die helfen wir diesen menschen mit mit
dem vorgehen aktuell
und das habe ich auch in ihrer
dokumentation gesehen wir haben vor
einiger zeit hier schon mal drüber
gesprochen über dieses erstaunliche
paradoxon dass trotz dieser zustände
viele afghanen froh sind dass
amerikaner auch deutsche der sogenannte
westen
soldaten die sie als besatzer gesehen
hatten dass die weg sind warum
weil unfassbar viele fehler in
afghanistan gemacht wurden als
die us und nato truppen einmarschiert
sind um das land unter anderem dann
später auch von den taliban zu befreien
gab es ein teil der bevölkerung die sich
gefreut haben dass die unterdrücker weg
sind aber im laufe der jahre wurde der
krieg immer brutaler geführt
kollateralschäden gehörten zum alltag
der menschen insbesondere in den
provinzen
und die rolle der befreier veränderte
sich immer mehr mehr im laufe der jahre
also aus den befreiern wurden besatzer
und die taliban wurden immer mehr und
mehr zu einer widerstandsgruppe die
gerade in den provinzen sehr viel
rückhalt bekam heilsbringern quasi sie
waren die einzige alternative sie waren
diejenigen die gegen die ich sage mal
brutalen als besatzer wahrgenommen den
usa tisch drei truppen kämpften und
dementsprechend veränderte sich und
verlagerte sich immer mehr und mehr die
negative auch innerhalb des landes von
gut auf böse und beziehungsweise vom
böse auf gut zu den taliban und es sind
sehr viele fehler gemacht wurden und
einer der größten fehler war womöglich
zu denken dass man mit hilfe von bomben
terrorismus abschaffen kann was aber
passiert es in den 20 jahren ist dass
der terrorismus in afghanistan wuchs und
wuchs und afghanistan das vorher relativ
weit von unten bei einem terrorismus end
index wurde in diesen 20 jahren zum zu
dem land mit den meisten
terroranschlägen auf der welt und
dieses paradox das muss man sich erst
mal bewusst machen dass der krieg gegen
den terror nicht nur zu mehr terror
geführt hat sondern eine
terror-organisation
zur regierung eines landes gemacht hat
es gibt in der dokumentation des teils
bizarre szenen sie treffen diese leute
sie setzen mit denen zusammen sie essen
mit den taliban zu abend
mal sozusagen vom einfach vom
fondsmanagement herrn gefragt sind das
leute die ernsthaft zum land führen
können sind die in der lage zu verstehen
wie wirtschaftliche zusammenhänge sind
worauf es ankommt wie man vielleicht
investoren ins land holt wie wie ein
land einfach zu funktionieren hat
wir wissen mittlerweile über die taliban
dass sie möglicherweise gute kämpfer
sind also immerhin haben sie tasten
wichtigste militärbündnis der welt
besiegt
aber die taliban haben keine
regierungserfahrung sie wissen nicht wie
man ein land regieren sind da unten sind
ja profis am werk man eine politik an so
amateure da sind amateure am werk und
genau diese kombination aus dieser
schwierigen wirtschaftslage plus einer
regierung oder einer selbst ernannten
regierung die eigentlich keine ahnung
davon hat wie man ein land zu führen hat
steuert afghanistan gerade in einen
absoluten abgrund
ist das nicht tragisch wenn man sich
überlegt herr roth da haben speziell
auch die amerikaner aber auch die
deutsche unglaublich viel geld
investiert in die hand genommen aber
zugute gekommen auch wenn man ihre
dokumentation sieht ist dass einer so
kleinen korrupten hochgelobten elite
gibt kaum einen aus dem regierungsumfeld
der sich nicht irgendwann mit millionen
bereichert hat aber die einfache
landbevölkerung und die macht ein
großteil aus des landes ist bitter arm
geblieben
warum ist uns das 20 jahre
entgangen
wir haben natürlich ganz
unterschiedliche ziele in den
mittelpunkt des militärischen engagement
ausgerückt am anfang war es die
beseitigung von
terrorismusgefahren dann geht es um den
aufbau einer wie auch immer gearteten
demokratie ich habe mir dann gesagt den
satz einer hohen repräsentanten der
evangelischen kirche von deutschland
nichts ist gut in afghanistan niemals zu
eigen gemacht hat weil es auch zynisch
ist das leben berger derzeit es ist
nicht alles gut gewesen aber es hat
zumindestens wir den aufbau von
infrastruktur gewesen gegeben frauen
hatten wieder zugang zum öffentlichen
raum mädchen konnten wieder die schule
besuchen es wurden krankenhäuser
errichtet es ist investiert worden aber
natürlich ist das ein in sich
kleptokraten
korruptes system gewesen wo nicht nicht
allen wohlstand zu gute gekommen ist und
es gab ja auch nicht ohne grund in
deutschland sehen
gut er merkt nicht nicht allen nur eine
minderheit hat davon profitiert aber
dennoch würde ich am strand so habe ich
sie ja auch verstanden frau lori ist die
lage jetzt nach dem abzug der nato
soldatinnen und soldaten nach der
beendigung dieses einsatzes und nach dem
abrupten abzug vor allem auch der
us-truppen ist ist es nicht besser
geworden es ist eher noch schlechter
geworden vor allem für die frauen
ist es nicht besser geworden
und wie es geht jetzt um die frage wie
kann man in einem solchen system wo
unprofessionelle menschen eine
terror-organisation herrschen die sich
auch nicht an die zusagen halten es gab
ja zu sagen es kommen nicht neue
terroristen in das land die rechte von
mädchen und von frauen werden geschützt
diese zusagen sind ja nicht eingehalten
worden die kann man jetzt trotzdem der
bevölkerung helfen wir haben im juli das
erdbeben gehabt ich sehe keinen plan 50
prozent der bevölkerung sind von hunger
bedroht was wir jetzt leisten wir haben
ja gerade wieder eine große konferenz
gehabt ist hilfe zur notwendigsten also
ernährung medizinische versorgung das
wird da gebe ich ihnen aber recht nicht
reichen die frage ist was tut man mit
einem solchen land in dem eine regierung
herrscht die sich ganz bewusst abwendet
von unseren werten von unseren
vorstellungen die auch nicht mit uns
kooperieren möchte die wir natürlich
schon geld haben möchte und wir müssen
jetzt mit entwicklungs instrumenten
dafür sorgen dass trotzdem die menschen
hoffnung haben dass trotzdem die
menschen dort leben können überleben
können das ist alles nicht schön das ist
alles dramatisch das ist alles bitter
und ist alles enttäuschend und das zeigt
sich eben auch wenn man einfach knall
auf fall ein land verlässt nach 20
jahren weil wir alle müde waren ob
dieses krieges ob dieses einsatzes dass
das auch keine verantwortungsvolle
entscheidung gewesen ist ich hoffe es
zumindest dass wir daraus denn deswegen
gibt es jetzt auch einen
untersuchungsausschuss im bundestag es
gibt noch ein kit kommission was können
wir aus diesen fehlern die sie
geschrieben haben für die zukunft lernen
vor kleinen ich meinen mann sehr
wichtigen satz gesagte demut vor dem
krieg selbstverständlich das ist ja
wichtig auch in bezug auf die ukraine
ich glaube dass wir es hier mit sehr
unterschiedlichen konstellationen aber
zu tun haben die auch wichtig sind
nochmal hervorzuheben in der ukraine
statt der einen anderen staat
angegriffen hat ein angriffskrieg von
außen die bevölkerung in der ukraine
unterstützt nach allen meinungsumfragen
den abwehrkampf gegen die ukraine nach
wie vor mit extrem hohen
zustimmungswerten also das ist ein
widerstands wille der bevölkerung der da
ist und der auch genau die frage
westlicher waffen unterstützung fordert
also das ist noch mal eine andere
konstellation ich war ich einfach nur
noch mal herausstreichen
frau muri sie abschließend gefragt
was ist jetzt zu tun
und wie kann speziell die rolle
deutschlands aus dem zusammenhang sie
haben ja gerade etwas wichtiges gesagt
nämlich sie wollen geld und aktuell ist
das eigentlich das größte druckmittel
denn die taliban
hatten keinen so richtigen plan was
passiert wenn sie das land erobert haben
zumindest macht das den anschein und
haben vielleicht gedacht die gelder
fließen vielleicht uneingeschränkt
weiter und meine gespräche mit
verschiedenen taliban auch aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium ergeben dass da
eine sehr große bereitschaft ist
eigentlich zu sprechen wenngleich sie
vielleicht nicht unsere werte umsetzen
möchten allerdings ist ja gerade ihr
ersuchen nach anerkennung und ihr suchen
nach geld
unfassbar
richtig groß und den polizeifunk nackte
überleben genau denn die hand eigenen
akten politische und sie und ihre
gesamte legitimation beruht ja darauf
dass sie das land irgendwie in unter
kontrolle gebracht haben die kontrolle
wird aber weichen wenn die wirtschaft
komplett kollabiert das heißt die
taliban hatten ein sehr sehr großes
interesse an dem geld des westens und
der westen kann das nutzen und die
taliban zu isolieren beziehungsweise
nicht mit ihnen zu sprechen weil sie
natürlich ein frauen verachtendes regime
führen könnte uns natürlich wieder die
90er jahre zurück bringen denn damals
wurden die taliban auch isoliert
letztendlich und haben sich auch selbst
isoliert und was passiert afghanistan
wurde zur drehscheibe des globalen
terrorismus am ende und wenn wir das
nicht wollen dass sich das wiederholt
müssen wir eine konstruktive
kommunikationsebene mit dem finden
insbesondere für die menschen im land